hello everyone and welcome to the core
today what it's tournament to the rapid
section is over after three days Magnus
Carlsen won the event with well with
quite and quite an edge and now we are
heading into the two days of blitz the
first day of blitz is over and we're
only you're gonna show a few games now
so I'll not be mentioning the the
results of the other games or the
standings we're gonna check that out
after I throw a few more games as these
are blitz games so we're not gonna be
really dwelling too long on them and as
you can see I'm back in my usual
surroundings so I do hope the sound and
everything is better now so without
further ado let's check out the game
Magnus cross and versus must-see
mashallah graph without further ado
let's check out the game cross and opens
with efore and of course that means he's
willing to take on a Mac seems night off
which is well one of the strongest night
of you can face with Maxine being such
such an expert on the opening night to
f3 we have d6 d4 and C captures on d4
Knight captures on d4 Knight to f6
Knight to c3 and as we mentioned the
neither of Defense's on the board with
Bishop to e3 asking Carlsen maybe maybe
you're interested sorry actually asking
Maxime maybe he's interested to go in
for that a nice to g4 line that we've
already seen in the rapid section but
here Maxine goes for e5 and okay Carson
can decide whether he wants to retreat
the b3 he can go to d2 he didn't go to
have three he decides for f3 Bishop to
e7 and now comes Bishop to c4 by Carlsen
we have castles castles and now comes
the Bishop to e6 and calls and retreats
with Bishop to b3 so this is nothing new
this is all very standard for this
opening with b5 usual idea and as blacks
plan will at some point be to push d5
which is of course what every player
wants to do that places the Sicilian
cousin goes Bishop to g5 he just attacks
one of the defenders of the d5 square so
if such a move ever happens then of
course Coulson is or just ready to
capture that night we have Knight B to
d7 preparing h6
as then cousin would have to decide
whether he wants to retreat with the
bishop or trade on f6
so black will be able to recapture with
the night we have rook to e1 rook the c8
now
developing the rook we have a 3-bike
Rossum and this position has been
reached before and there the move played
there was nice to e8 where black offered
a trade of dark square bishop so but
here Maxine goes for h6 it is the top
move recommended by the engine so Maxima
of course knows his openings especially
the night off as we've already mentioned
and our Carlsen can choose whether he
wants to retreat and then go into
something like that b6 from where the
knight can come to c4 again attack the
bishop and that Knights really going to
be an annoying piece so here after h6
cross and decides to just capture it
with Bishop captures and Knight captures
and now comes Knight the d2 if you're
interesting about captures and captures
yes you do mess up black's pawn
structure somewhat but in the Sicilian
it's important to have a strong center
this way black would get a semi-open F
file and then d5 it will be even even
easier to execute as the e pawn also
controls the d5 square so after Knight
captures on f6 we have night 2 d2 by
crossing I'm now preparing f3 Knight so
f1 and then well depending on what black
plays eater Knights the e3 or g3 with
Bishop to g4 now a provoking f3 with an
f3 and now comes Queen to b6 check King
to h1 and now Bishop returns to d6
square and now we have night 2 f1 as
planned by Carlsen and here comes rook
to c5 just a nice square for the rooks
and scolson no longer has a dark square
Bishop it's not very easy to dislodge
this route from the c5 square maxime is
also preparing to double up rooks on the
C file with Knights - III by Crossin
rook F to see it as planned and the now
comes Luke - E - it will be a good
defender of the
of the c2 square if the bishop ever
moves and of course if the knight ever
moves but here Maxime goes for well
something it's not the engines favorite
move but it is every night horse player
favorite move and of course if you're a
knight affair you know what I'm talking
about
rook captures on c3 so it's a standard
exchange sacrifice in the night or
always giving up this rook for for the
knight on c3 be captures on c3 rook
captures on c3 now with a double attack
against cousins night and e3 and you
have
to be careful if you defend it with
Queen c1 of course then just a bunch of
characters you will not be able to
recapture due to this pin so present
defended with Quinta II one now of
course the rock and queen are guarding
the night we have Queen to c6 and now
comes a for cousin says okay there is
nothing to be worried about here if you
get from my Bishop I'm just gonna
capture here on unbe five and then I'm
gonna have the a file open for my rook
but with before Maxime prefers to have
his rook cemented in the c3 square and
now comes Knights the d1 where if black
just retreats with rook to c5 now you
have a problem because now Bishop
captures on e6 is possible F captures
Queen captures on b4 and now after Luke
captures and c2 rook captures and Queen
captures you would get Knights to e3
with an attack on the Queen let's say
Queen D 3 and now Queen a3 defending the
knight offering a queen trade and here
cross and would just be able to to enjoy
his him being up the exchange so after
this night that he won move maxime goes
for well a seemingly temporary
exchange sacrifice but not really he
plays Bishop capture son b3 and okay
cousin recaptures we looked at first on
c3 and now Maxime just brings back the
bishop with an attack on Carlson's rook
Bishop to c4 and now you can't react to
this attack on the rook because then you
also lose the knight on c3 so you do
have to save the peace with Knights to
d1 Maxime captures Bishop capture Sonny
to Queen capture Sonny - and now finally
as it became possible
Maxime pushes d5 and he gets rid of his
weak d6 pawn and now the bishop can also
come into play
we have ecad press on d4 Knight captures
on d4 and here the e5 pawn is off-limits
if cross and grabs at the dangers Bishop
to f6 you don't win the rook right away
but you will win it
after this variation Queen B Queen b6
check
sorry convey eight check King gauge
seven and now you do have to move the
rook let's say you move it Roxy one now
I just get Bishop to g5 again you have
to move the rook rook moves and now
Queen captures can see - and now bunch
of to f6 will be it will come again and
you will not be
to defend Europe let's the Queen e8 now
comes a bishop to f6 the rook is under
attack and now you have to give back the
exchange with let's say Roxy one Queen
captures Queenie forecheck we'll pick up
the night I say g6 Queen captures but
black will just have our winning endgame
I mean White has nothing to show for and
well humble I can just play anything
Queen c2 start pushing the past pawn and
it's all over
so after this Knight captures on d5 move
you cannot capture Magnus go squinty for
just pins the night here and here we
have Queen to e6 unpinning and you know
keeping everything in order so cross and
still up the exchange but he still has
to figure out a way how to get this rock
into the game so night to e3
hoping to trade nights and then just
play rook to d1 or look to e1 but Knight
to c3
first attacking Carlson's Queen the
bishop also guards the before pawn so
you don't you don't have the option of
capturing that Queen the c4 hoping for a
trade but Queen to g6 not by Maxine and
here cross and just pushes a5 improving
his position in the Queen side saying
okay I'm still just up the exchange
Maxine has nothing here he's just you
know he's trying to trying to trick me
so
maxime doesn't like the idea of Quinta
CA to check where he will constantly
have to be calculating things he can
block it with her either with Bishop to
f8 or just you know and I said premature
King to h7 getting the King out of
harm's way with rook to e1 finally
Carlson I brings the rook into the game
and the now comes c4 again
maxime constantly playing active moves
and this is the way Maxine plays if you
remember previous time he faced Carlsen
he sacrificed upon but it wasn't enough
so here again it's nice to see that you
know his spirits are still up and he
continues to come at Coulson with F
captures on e4 now comes Knight captures
on e4 and here one of the more important
moments in the game you do have to
prevent night to have to check it's very
important to do that and to do it
properly you have to play Queen to d5
just keep an eye on the f5 square with
the Queen and the night and now if this
comes in I have to check in g1 I should
recheck you can escape with King to f1
now both the Queen and the nightguard DF
v square no Queen f5 check is possible
but here crossing played Knights the d5
a more active move also now he opens up
a double attack towards the night here
and if the knight moves then just the
Knight captures Bishop it seems like
black is black is over here but you know
things aren't always as they seem
here at night to have to check has been
played King to g1 and mount Knight to h3
check and here a person has to decide
whether he wants to go king h1 and allow
this perpetual or does he want to play
actively which he did if he did not
agree for this perpetual he played King
to f1 and now he allows the maxime to
start an attack against Collison scheme
we have Queen to f5 check now you can
see that not the night nor the Queen are
the defending the f5 square with King to
e2 and now not Queen to f2 check seems
nice but after King do you want you
don't have any more checks and you're
just worse white will win this game but
rather Queen to e5 check and now seems
very dangerous because you're aligning
your Queen and Bishop with the rook so
what what's Maxine's idea here here
Crossing place Knights the e3 the
problem is if you play something like
king d2 then you get Bishop g5 check you
get Bishop out of Bishop out of harm's
way and after let's say rook blocks
let's say rook III now get Knight f2 and
you've gotten your Bishop and your night
out of harm's way after crossing on pins
you would capture here captures captures
and now you have this position where
black is just better do to do to call
sense loose skin here on e - so after
Queen e5 check cross and decided to go
for night the e3 and now we have Knight
to f4 check getting the knight out of
harm's way without losing time so of
course it comes with check King back to
F 1 and now comes Knight the e6 blocking
any future looks attack towards the
bishop here and here cos and decides
well it's hard to decide what to do here
it's a blitz game you know everyone has
a few seconds on the clock but you do
want to play Knight to d5 again open up
an attack from the roof to the Queen and
keep an eye on this Bishop here but here
across and decided to grab the a6 pawn
and now it's well it's really
just an exciting game he allows Queen
captures on h2 so what do you do here
first Queen to d3 check getting the
Queen out of the way we have King to g8
and now cross and created a path bone
which is a very dangerous pawn
now you but you do have to keep an eye
on any threats that are happening on the
Kings side we have Knight to d5 bite and
Knight to d5 is a move Carson should
have played but he played a six but the
problem with a6 is the following if cost
and play Knight to d5 then Maxine's idea
would not be possible Maxime played
Bishop to h4 not here I'm maxing played
Bishop page four in the line where where
we mentioned a6 was played but here I'm
just gonna show why Maxine's idea
doesn't work or better yet I'm just
gonna show you what a magazine played
across and played a six and then Maxim
replied with Bishop to h4 and here you
have a huge problem if rookie two then
the king can no longer escape vrd2
square let's say rookie to Queen h1 is
checkmate on the other hand if you move
the rook somewhere else lets you go all
the way to a 1 then you get night at 4
again Knight controls D 2 square and the
Queen and now again after we move the
Queen Queen h1 will be checkmate so
that's the problem with this a 6 move
Carlsen played heavy play Knight to d5
then the ship h4 doesn't really do all
that much as now you can just play Queen
to h3 it's important to open up the
Queen's path to the h3 square now you'd
have to eat a trade or move the Queen
let's say Queen b6 and now after Queen
captures Queen captures on d5 you would
capture on before and now you enjoyed
this better position where you can just
well try and escort your past point of
the board and win the game so this was
the way to go for Coulson like I said he
played a six and now Maxine's idea
becomes possible push up to h4 and now
and this is defensive resource no longer
exists
it's too slow to now move the knight so
cross and played Queen to d2 but here
Maxime again just played Knight to f4
and it was in this position that world
champion magnus carlsen resigned the
game so the the the unbeaten streak
lasted for a long time and it's I mean
it's fine for him he still unbeaten has
his streak in the classical time format
but he had like 70
unbeaten streak in all the time formats
combined so not now he no longer has
that but you know that's just the way
chess works and here he resigns because
it's a similar idea to the one we've
shown there's no defense against Queen
to h1 checkmate
the bishop controls all the squares here
the knight controls this square so
there's no way to prevent it and if you
play g3 then okay if Queen h1 now you do
have the f2 Square for a king but you
can just capture with the quick or you
can just capture whites Queen that's
also possible but it's also way cooler
to play Queen captures than g3 and now
again whatever white plays white just
gets to checkmate let's say Knight g2
now you get Queen f3 check King to g1
and now the awesome move of course you
will see it I'll even let you pause the
video here and try to find the move it's
a very nice hypothetical line that never
happened for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent solver of positions that never
happened actually over the board and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy the
show not Bishop captures a1 because then
Queen captures and f4 becomes possible
but rather bushel to have to check it's
really a nice idea because now you
either play Queen captures and you get
neither g3 check you lose the Queen and
the game of course or you just move the
King doesn't matter if you move it to f1
or h1 because now the bishop blocks the
Queen's defense of the night and just
Queen captures and g2 will be checkmate
so really an amazing game by Maxime and
really really shows us how to play the
night or if doesn't really matter those
who care what the engine thinks don't
don't play the night off here you play
the way neither should we played the way
it's been written in books you just take
and c3 with your rook you give up the
road for a night and then you play a
nice active game push d5 and then you
know just defeat the world champion
Magnus cross and that's that's how you
how we do it so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it like I said we're
gonna show a few more games from round
one of the blitz section I'm checking up
on your suggestions so be sure to
suggest as I wasn't able iacquire go in
so a few games not all of them so if you
if you know the games that are great do
share them so you know I don't have to
look for them myself that would be great
and also I would like to thank Eliezer
battambang Gary Williams constant
Konstantinos locus Joffrey Lewis and
Rafa Grishka for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing this Court's d'Ivoire saga in
the Blitz section checking up on your
suggestions and of course well I'm just
trying to trying to catch up with with
everything that's going on in in the
chess world and also thank you all for
your vast emails regarding the chess
manga we are going through them all and
I will get back to you soon on how our
progress is going so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and have an
excellent rest of your Sunday and I will
see you soon